yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video we're diving deep into that shock
twist season four finale what it means
for season five plus all the clues
callbacks and easter eggs that predicted
the big ending spoilers ahead of course
so take care
season four ends on a bombshell with
silver's dirty tricks paying off as
kobra kai win the tournament but kris's
victory is short-lived as silva has him
arrested after getting stingray to frame
kris for assault by preying on raymond's
weakness to be part of cobra kai and
silva plans to take over the dojo
franchise all for himself now he's got
rid of his own weakness i'm shedding my
weakness captain although silva's
betrayal comes as a shock decrease there
is no one in the world i trust more than
you it was hinted at back in the opening
episode turns out you disappearing was
the best thing that ever happened to me
as the head of kobrakai and a former
army captain kris is used to being the
one in control giving orders and he
regards silva as his weak underling do
you remember the cage we both thought we
were gonna die i wasn't afraid you were
if it wasn't for me you'd still be back
in that pit but silva used creases
attitude against him this season what
your opponent is thinking is key if they
think you're weak that's when you can
surprise him with your strength although
previously silva has happily repaid
kris's life saving in vietnam over the
years anything you need i'm there for
you after so many decades he's grown
sick of crease continually throwing it
in his face how many times do you expect
me to repay that debt before we swear as
kris himself said this season to be a
cobra car you have to have a killer
instinct and that's exactly what silva
has in the end another hint to silva's
behind-the-scenes machinations against
his old army pal came when we saw him
reading leviathan by thomas hobbs who
argued that a strong ruler or government
with absolute powers was necessary to
live in peace and avoid war and social
conflict the book was written during the
english civil war and the constant
fighting between kobrakai
eaglefangamyagido could be seen as an
analogy and with silva now taking over
kobrakai and disbanding the competition
he might well see himself as bringing
peace and stability to the karate world
in the valley
it's most unlikely though that silva's
seen the last of crease as he won't go
down without fighting back as he said in
the first episode you know people expect
men of our age to pack it in but i still
have some fight left in me indeed silva
would do well to remember what happened
to their first captain in vietnam when
he took on crease that was a seminal
moment for crease becoming the man we
know today as even when the possibility
arose for both men to make it out of
their battle alive chris chose no mercy
in season 4 though we've seen a few
cracks increase his no mercy mantra for
instance he told silva to go easy on
johnny after he confronted him and
encouraged tory to play it fair in the
tournament in contrast to how he urged
his own students to use dirty tactics in
the original karate kid i'm surprised
you backed off on nickels in the finals
that's not like you i had a moment of
sympathy it seems chris is getting a
sense of how wrong his extreme methods
have been and it's a hint that he could
follow a redemption path of sorts in the
future especially if he finds that
johnny repays that small act of kindness
by helping crease get out of his
predicament and we'll see whether
stingray ends up retracting his
accusation against kris or if he simply
becomes silver's yes man and punching
bag at kobrakai given his desperate
desire to belong
although silva seems on top of the
karate world by the end he'll likely
have to reckon with some fallout from
tori in season five because although he
claims he's changed since the wild
events of karate kid 3 i'm not that man
anymore in reality he's just got more
devious so instead of using his vast
fortune to require a killer karate kid
of his own you just bought yourself a
champion now he takes a more direct
route with his money bribing the
tournament referee to ensure a cobra kai
win silva's cheating not only robs the
other dojos of a fair chance at the
title it also robs tory of the sense of
accomplishment and validation she's so
desperate for if i could just win this
one time then i could look at that
trophy and know i was best at something
so how will she handle the situation now
she knows she didn't win fair and square
will she keep quiet or will she stand up
to silva especially if she discovers his
part increases downfall to answer that
let's go back to her final fight
remember after she accidentally elbowed
sam in the eye that silva insisted she
do the same again but deliberately this
time she can't see she can't fight which
by the way was one of his rules when he
trained daniel in the third movie and
part of the pain-provoking strategy he
got mike barnes to employ in the final
tournament well tori was having none of
that in her finals give her a shot to
the other eye when i get disqualified i
don't need to cheat to win a moment
which takes me back to the original
movie and bobby's fight against daniel i
want him out of position but i'll be
disqualified except in tory's case she
sticks to her guns and chris actually
backs his student this time let her do
what she wants this is your fight now so
whatever happens it's up to you because
johnny reminded chris what he put him
through back in the day he forced me to
fight dirty sweep the leg sacrificed my
soul just so cobra kai could stay number
one so perhaps now tory knows the
referee was paid off silva may well end
up regretting the advice that he gave
the kobrakai students earlier this
season take all that anger and store it
because you're gonna need it when the
time comes robbie may also prove a
problem for silva in season five
especially after robbie gets a wake-up
call that he's not been the kind of
mentor he hoped to be when he finds new
kid kenny punching former bully anthony
in the locker room this is not how i
trained you it's called bakai no mercy
intentionally or not that cobra kai no
mercy mantra is what robbie rammed home
to kenny during their tournament fight
and because robbie put passion in front
of principal he ended up proving true
the miyagi-ism that even if you win you
lose johnny warned his son about his old
sensei earlier this season crease is
brainwashing you just like he
brainwashed me and daniel also drew on
his own karate kid 3 experience to warn
robbie about silva one day you'll find
yourself with some poor kid's blood all
over your shirt and he'll just hope it's
not too late to change course but robbie
believed he wasn't like his dad or
daniel he was in control of the
situation using cobra kai to get what he
wanted taking their best and mixing it
with miyagidou in the end though kris's
insistence that nothing matters but
winning it's about being a champion that
reputation will follow you the rest of
your life still manage to pollute
robbie's mindset and i'll use whatever
it takes to win the upshot of it all is
that instead of forging his own path as
he believed he was robbie has actually
been perpetuating the damaging merciless
cycle kicked off in the 1980s by kris
who learned it from his captain in
vietnam then passed it on to silva
johnny robbie and now to kenny so in the
end robbie has taken a similar road
filled with obsession and hatred as both
his sensei and his dad once took i had
all this hate inside of me and i thought
i could use gogokai to control that but
it just made things worse however
robbie's recognition of what he's done
is a step towards changing things and it
also opens the way to reconciliation
with his father i'm sick of blaming you
dad that's gonna be all right and
there's more hope ahead for this next
generation of karate kids as daniel and
johnny also eventually recognize that
the way they've been acting was more
about protecting themselves and proving
a point than looking out for the best
interests of their students you and i
may be setting our ways but these kids
they can learn from both of us and use
what we teach them and create their own
way too often all the senseis have used
their students to prove themselves right
and feed their own egos teaching them
the brief sugar rush of self-esteem that
comes with winning instead of teaching
them true resilience and self-compassion
which is gracious in victory and sees
setbacks as a chance to learn you kicked
ass today could have gone either way
don't let it eat you up trust me
although johnny may have begun to repair
the relationship with his son robbie in
the finale his role as a father figure
to miguel is on the rocks by the end and
miguel decides to leave home and find
his biological father i looked him up
says he lives in mexico now johnny and
miguel's relationship comes under strain
when miguel trains at miyagido and gets
closer to daniel he also becomes a
father figure for a while teaching him
about fixing cars and opening up a
different world view johnny's attempts
to reconnect go horribly wrong when he
confesses he wants to be a good father
to miguel while drunk i love you i love
you too robbie their faltering
relationship comes to a head just before
his tournament fight with hawk whose
side are you on yours are you sure whose
side are you on what do you mean i'm on
your side
always that combined with his
catastrophic fall and injury makes
miguel reconsider everything and
johnny's words show me you're ready to
be a man appear to be the final straw in
the letter he leaves he says karate
isn't enough anymore and he needs to
know where he came from to understand
himself johnny tells carmen he'll bring
miguel home and given that tanabu cannon
has been involved in season five filming
in puerto rico presumably standing in
for scenes set in mexico it looks like
robbie will also be going along for the
trip although miguel knows his father's
been involved in illegal activity what
his mother never told him was that his
father doesn't actually know miguel even
exists so he could end up in a lot of
trouble when he presumably manages to
track his dad down
midway through the season the show
already starts teeing up more of the
original cast from the karate kid movies
to make a splashy return in season five
are there any other cobra kais from your
past that are gonna come out of the
woodwork and destroy our lives no i
can't say that for sure and i'd lay
money on a comeback from tournament
terror mike barnes the karate bad boy
that silver employed to wreak revenge on
daniel and mr miyagi after crease went
out of business bonds has already popped
up in previous seasons via photos and
film footage and this season daniel
drops his name when he tells johnny
about their fight and after i beat
barnes i never saw silver again but what
seals the deal in my mind for barnes's
return is what silva says to crease as
his former captains hauled off by the
police in the finale i'm sure i can dig
up an old friend or two to help out with
cobra kai while you deal with your legal
problem actor sean kanan who played
barnes in the 80s has said we probably
haven't seen the last of mike that he
certainly open to returning and is a fan
of the new show and when asked if barnes
might have become a better person over
the years he said he hoped so as he
thought barnes had got a bunch of bad
wiring and messages as a kid but was
young enough then that with the right
kind of mentorship he could have turned
it around given his negotiating skills
in the movie maybe barnes would be keen
to try and get a steak and silver's new
cobra kai franchise you fight as hard as
you negotiate harder you got you 50
whatever barnes's role in the show ends
up being kanan has said he'd like to
bring a lot more colours to the
character as he thought he was pretty
one-dimensional back then along with
barnes i wonder if we could also see
some of silva's henchmen back again that
snake who was played by jonathan
alvardson cena the director of the
original trilogy and dennis played by
skilled martial artist and actor william
christopher ford another blast from the
past who we know will certainly be back
for season five is chosen after
appearing in season three during
daniel's trip to okinawa chosen is now
stateside and is all ready to team up
with his former rival to take down cobra
kai as daniel implies he won't be
honoring his season 3 agreement with
kris for the tournament losers to close
down their dojo there's too much at
stake to honor an agreement made with
men who have none will you help me
finally put an end to cobra kai this is
the second time chosen has proven
crucial in a cobra high finale at the
end of season three the secret miyagi
pressure points he previously taught
daniel saved his ex-enemy during his
fight with crease if an enemy insists on
war then you take away their ability to
wage it and now after mending bridges
last season and if it means anything
chosen i forgive you it means a great
deal chosen and daniel are joining
forces at mr miyagi's graveside complete
with one of his beloved bonsai trees
given that after the events of karate
kid 2 chosen became part of the miyagido
family in okinawa and has been for many
years it seems likely there will be less
friction between these two new allies
than there was between daniel and johnny
when they tried to work together and i'm
curious whether he'll reveal any more
new miyagi techniques next season season
4 is also loaded with even more easter
eggs hidden references and callbacks to
the original karate kid movies which
i'll go into in more detail in my things
you missed video i'll add the link here
and in the video description as soon as
it's ready so what did you think of the
latest season and what would you like to
see happen in season five leave your
comments below and if you enjoyed this
don't forget to leave a thumbs up it's
hugely appreciated tap left to discover
all the easter eggs and details you
might have missed in season four thanks
for watching and see you next time
yupikai movie lovers